sau 12 ngày làm việc hình trường nghiêm tục và trích nhiệm cao kì họ tự nhiết của gồi khoảng
18h thành tòn buồn trưng trình đe ra và chính thức bế mạng.
Dương phên bế mạc có tổng bị thư trụ tịch nước Tổ lâm cũng các đồng trí lấy đạo,
người lĩnh đạo đạo nhà nước.
Pháp biểu bế mạc trụ tịch của gồi trình thành lẫn nhấn mạnh.
Ngay sau cuộc mục gửu, phúc hồi đánh gành trống trình khai khu lực lượng lớn công việc hệ trọng
từ kịch toàn tụi chiếc bộ mấy, mồ các trực dành lĩnh đạo cấp cao đến
cứ điện các vấn đề phát triển kinh tế xa hội phòng an ninh và đối ngoại.
Chỉ trong một kì họ, phúc hồi đả xem sát, quyết định và mà chính nhân sự cấp cao
thông qua chỉ lợt và bà mốt nghi quyết nhiều độ dùng đặt ti lệ đồng tất nối.
Các chính xác bà hành vừa măng tính cấp bách, vừa có tình dành dài hạt,
gó phần tháo gửi mạng, kỳ thông gồn lực thuv đề phát triển.
Phúc hồi phúc đà thông qua các kế hoại phát triển năm năm,
hành gình không chân ngày sau, hành gình không chân bà người đặt mục tiêu ông định kinh tế viên mồ,
kìm xuất đặt phát bảo đam các tình đối lưỡn và giống tới tăng trường hai con số.
Đáng chú ý, khu hồi đả cuối định thành lập thành phố đồng này thông qua chân trình giám sát,
hành gình không chân hành bà bà xanh sát nhiều bà cáo quan trọng liên quan đến cử chi tiết kiểm trống lạng phi.
Chủ tiên khu hồ đề nghị, ngay sau khi họ chính phủ và các cửa quan liên quan,
hình chương trình khai các lột li quyết, không đề khoảng trống pháp li, bảo đam các quyết xách đang chống đi vào cuộc sống.
Hành định thành công của kì hoặc tạo khi thế và đồng lực mới cho cả những kì,
chủ tế khu hồ nhấn mạnh, yêu cầu tiên tục đối mấy mạnh mẽ mà đậm của khu hồn,
lưng cao chất lượng lập pháp giám sát đáp ứng kì vào cuộc chi và nhân dần.